so let's follow up on the impact of this
Devon Nunez memo I sort of saw the Devon
Nunez memo which we've now exposed as a
total nothing burger the memo was sort
of the last and the last attempt to take
down the robert muller investigation
into trump russia collusion and as i
told you it was such a milquetoast and
embarrassing non blockbuster i call it a
non burger it's it's i like that term
better than i've been a nothing burger
it was total soy to use the the
phraseology of many of the hatreds in
the audience so to speak the republican
party now is effectively fully at war
with the FBI and once again over the
weekend donald trump trashing the FBI on
Twitter tweeting quote the four-page
memo released friday reports the
disturbing fact about how the FBI and
FISA appear to have been used to
influence the 2016 election and it's
aftermath the FBI failed to inform the
FISA Court that the Clinton campaign had
funded the dossier the FBI became a tool
of anti Trump political actors this is
unacceptable in a democracy and ought to
alarm anyone who wants the FBI to be a
nonpartisan enforcer of the law the FBI
wasn't straight up with Congress as it
hid most of these facts from
investigators recall that Donald Trump
previously referred to the entire
intelligence community as equivalent to
the Nazis and this is having an impact
there's a new poll that was done for
Axios which shows that under 40% of
Republicans now approve of the FBI and
approve of the main federal law
enforcement infrastructure of the United
States and this is not all Republicans
right there are still reasonable
Republicans who either for reasons of
self-respect or they still have some
connection to the real world they're
saying wait wait a second hold on the
FBI is still trustworthy Robert Muller
has integrity but increasingly the
Republican Party and Donald Trump are
sort of in a war
with the FBI and the American
intelligence apparatus and in fact you
can see the more reasonable Republicans
looking to bail we've seen a number of
Republicans announcing that they're
either retiring or resigning or not
running for re-election and it's very
clearly the rats jumping out of the
sinking ship and just consider the
positioning of this trumpian wing of the
Republican Party they're there or with
the FBI
they're at war with the intelligence
community more broadly many of them just
straight-up not believing the consensus
assessment of multiple American
intelligence agencies that Russia
attempted to meddle in the 2016 election
doesn't even mean they impacted the
results right
that they were involved in trying to
sway the results not accepting that and
you've got a whole bunch of the
leadership of the Justice Department
which Donald Trump has been either
pushing to resign or threatening to fire
and more than half of American voters
now disagree with that most of the rest
of the world is at odds with the hard
trumpian right and then you also have
Donald Trump who referred to most
American media as the enemy of the
American people which is straight-up
authoritarian talk and meanwhile you
have Donald Trump insisting that he has
great relationships with world leaders
that he will build great relationships
with other world leaders if given the
opportunity except when you actually
look at the few friendly relationships
that Donald Trump has with other world
leaders it's the authoritarian dictator
esque individuals like Rodrigo Duterte
in the Philippines like Vladimir Putin
in Russia Turkey's president air Dewan
these are the types of people that
Donald Trump actually has alliances with
and meanwhile those who are even
tangentially connected to what we see is
Western democracies are moving away from
the United States and the Trumpy and
right will say that's good we don't need
them we don't want them but this is a
war that will have impact
this entire war with the intelligence
community the firings the threats of
firings the nothing Berger memo
distractions it's all because Donald
Trump doesn't respect the separation of
powers doesn't respect the independence
of the Robert Moeller investigation
which he supposedly believes wouldn't
turn anything up anyway because he's
totally innocent and that's where it has
to come full circle for anybody who can
step back and sort of see the big
picture here an innocent person doesn't
up turn everything that is good and
decent in terms of relationships with
the intelligence community with our law
enforcement entities over an
investigation that they actually believe
would eventually vindicate them they
would do the opposite right they would
get out of the way and say the
investigation will vindicate me I am
fully cooperating and I look forward to
hearing the final report that's not what
Trump is doing Trump is doing the
opposite and the real tragedy as usual
is not even the normalization of this
behavior but the hyper normalization
that's going on because a big part of
the Republican Party now the voters I'm
talking about now they see it as totally
normal for the president to demonize and
to baselessly attack law enforcement
agencies to basically attack robert
muller
who is a lifelong republican and someone
that up until just months ago had the
utmost respect of both Democrats and
Republicans at some previous point this
would have been unacceptable if Obama
did it they'd have called for his
unamerican communist head to be burned
at the stake but it's Trump and you've
got Republicans supporting this they're
emailing me I mentioned last week I
predict some of these hard right Trump
ian's will email me and they'll say good
for Trump for considering the
prosecution or firing of robert muller
he should be considering that and that's
exactly what i got there there's this
dozen or so a group of a dozen or so
hard right Trumpets who emailed me and
they said Trump is right the FBI
and tatters good for him for taking a
stand and thinking about getting Robert
Muller out of there this is a problem
not only because of the facts but it's a
problem because of the normalization of
what is a completely undemocratic attack
on the checks and balances and
supposedly independent entities that we
have in American government and the
Republicans are complicit
they are absolutely complicit in this
and I just hope that eventually we will
not see the further interference with
the robert muller investigation because
Trump and an element of the right are
fully at war with those elements of the
law enforcement world of the United
States it's absolutely disgusting if it
were Obama I can't even speak just
imagine what we would be seeing and
hearing if it were Obama